Everyone is starting to realize how big
of a deal Anthropic's model context
protocol is. It's the first ever
standard for connecting LLMs to your
services like Gmail, Slack, GitHub, web
search, the list goes on. And you can
use it to give higher level capabilities
to your LLMs like long-term memory. As
we'll see in a couple of minutes here,
there are a lot of these MCP servers
already out there to connect us to these
different services. But the true power
comes in building our own so we can
connect our own agents to any service
that we want, all using the simplicity
and power of MCP. In this video, I'll be
breaking down the full process for you
on building your own MCP servers to
connect your agents to anything. And to
make it well worth your time, I'll also
be walking you through my template that
I've created for you to get you up and
running building your own MCP servers
very easily. I've spent hours creating
the perfect foundation for you to save
you a big headache. So, I'm really
excited to show you that and also just
how to build these servers in general. A
lot of value packed into this video
today. So, let's dive right into it. If
you are not familiar with Anthropics MCP
already, I would highly recommend
checking out this video, which I'll link
to above. But in general, the three main
resources that I use to learn about MCP
and building my own MCP servers are the
official docs for MCP, which we're
looking at right here, a list of
existing MCP servers on GitHub, and then
also Anthropic's official GitHub repo
for the MCP Python SDK. So, let me
explain all three of these really quick,
and then I'll also have links to these
in the description of this video. So,
the official docs are just really useful
to get a general grasp of MCP, and they
have pages for pretty much anything,
including building your own servers and
clients, which we'll be using in this
video. And then the existing list of MCP
servers is just very useful to use as a
reference point. You can use these
servers as examples for how to build
your own. And this is just a great
repository of a bunch of servers that we
probably will want to use ourselves just
in general and to help us build our own
servers. And then lastly, Python is the
language I'm going to be using to build
MCP servers. It's just the simplest and
the most used overall. And so using this
as general guidance for how to build MCP
servers specifically with Python is
very, very useful. Now, the first big
question I want to answer for you is
what does it really mean to build our
own MCP server? And to start, let's go
to the existing list. So you can click
into any of these MCP servers like Brave
Search to give our LLM very powerful web
search capabilities. We can scroll down
and see the configuration that we' put
into any MCP client. This is any
application that supports MCP like
Windsurf Cursor, N8N, Claw Desktop, your
own AI agents. There are so many
different places that we can use MCP to
give all these capabilities to our
agents and tools. And so you copy this
and then within the official MCP docs,
it shows you how to use MCP servers, get
that all hooked into cloud desktop. And
so we can go to our cloud desktop and
then follow those instructions to set up
our configuration. And so this is what
my config looks like right here. I just
pasted exactly what I copied from GitHub
into my cloud config and then set my
Brave API key. And then I even have a
couple of different MCP servers here
just to show you how you can use as many
as you want, combining all these tools
together to add all these new
capabilities to our LLM. Like I even
have Archon here, which is my open-
source AI agent builder, which I have
some exciting updates coming soon for
it, by the way. So stay tuned for that.
But anyway, that's our configuration.
And then back in Claw Desktop here, once
you restart, you'll have access to all
of these servers. I have a lot right
now. But now we can ask it a question
that it would only be able to answer if
it has access to a web search
capability. And so I'll let it use the
Brave MCP server for this chat. And then
boom, look at this. We now have
up-to-date information that usually with
the knowledge cutoff for LLMs, we
wouldn't be able to answer this kind of
question. So that's the power of MCP.
It's that easy to add new capabilities
to our LLMs to take them to the next
level for us. But there are some
limitations for this. Like what if the
way that this MCP server interacts with
Brave is not how we want to interact
with Brave? Or what if there's some
services or capabilities that we want to
work with that there isn't an existing
MCP server for? That's when we really
need to get down and dirty and build our
own MCP servers so we can interact with
the services we want and have the full
level of customization and control to
really make our agents do what we want
them to do. And that's what I'm going to
show you how to do in this video. Now,
the reason I showed using an existing
MCP server is I want to prove a point to
you that what we're about to create
together is going to work in exactly the
same way as all of the MCP servers that
you've already been working with. So,
I'm really setting the stage here to
show you that these servers that are
built by Anthropic, they follow all the
best practices and they work with every
client you can imagine. We're going to
build one that works in the same way.
And I'll even show you this is my new
updated cloud desktop configuration.
This is the MCP server that I'm building
as an example in this video. It
integrates with mem which is a library
to give long-term memory to our AI
agents. So we're going to make it so
that Claw Desktop can remember things
that we've said in past conversations.
It definitely doesn't have that
capability right now. And look at the
configuration for this. It's set up in
this JSON file exactly like all of our
other MCP servers. very nice and easy.
And the way that we interact with it and
the way that we build it as well, as
we'll see later, is also the same. And
so I can go back into claw desktop here
and I can ask it another question like
what are my memories? And this is going
to now use a tool not developed by
anthropic but by me and what you are
going to be able to create after this.
And so I'll allow it to get all
memories. And once it runs this tool,
it's going to tell me just one memory
that I like chicken cuz I kept it very
simple. I just inserted one memory into
the knowledge base right now. But yeah,
I was able to use this tool that I built
and retrieve that. It's so cool.
Everything looks the exact same, but now
we can add our own capabilities. So,
just because this is so exciting to me,
I want to show you really quick how we
can use this MCP server in a lot of
other ways as well with anything that
supports MCP. Like I have this custom
Pantic AI agent that I have connected to
my MCP server that's running locally
right now. So I can go in the terminal
and run a script that's going to ask it
for all my memories just like I did in
Claw Desktop. And because it's connected
to the same MCP server, it has the same
tool. We get the same answer back. And I
can even go into N8N and do the exact
same thing. So I'm showing you all these
different kinds of clients. I have yet
another one here with N8N connected to
the same MCP server. And so I can go
into my chat and just like before I can
ask it, what memories do I have? And
it's kind of boring. We're getting the
same answer every single time. But
that's the point. I'm showing you how we
have one MCP server that we're able to
connect to from all these different
clients and we built everything
ourselves. Take a look at that. You
currently have one memory. You like
chicken. It's a funny way to word it.
It's like we're we're dropped on the
severed floor and the only memory we
have is that we like chicken. So there
you go. If you know the reference, you
know the reference. But this is so neat.
We're able to connect with all these
clients. And so now let's dive into
building this server. and it's a
template that you can use to build
anything you want as well. So, here is
the Python MCP template that I have
spent hours preparing for you, really
trying to incorporate all of the best
practices for MCP that I see a lot of
people failing to implement. And so,
this is a MEM zero MCP server. So, I
wanted to build something that's
concrete and practical, but it's also
general enough. that's very basic where
you can just take out the mem zero
specific parts if you want and implement
all of your own tools to really build
this into your own MCP server following
all the different components that I'll
explain in a little bit that really
makes this a robust server that supports
the different transport protocols for
MCP as well which is a very important
thing and so the readme that we have at
the root of this GitHub repo that I'll
link to in the description of this video
it shows you how to set up and run
everything and you can follow these
instructions for your own server once
you have it set up following this
template as well. And the very important
thing with this is that just because you
can feed all the documentation into an
AI coding assistant to build a server
for you doesn't mean that it's going to
work all the time. And so another really
good use of this template is you can
just copy everything in this main
function and paste it in as a part of
your prompt to your AI coding assistant
when you're asking it like in Windsurf
cursor to build an MCP server for you.
This example is going to help the AI
coding assistant 10 times better than
any documentation that you can pull from
MCP to help it understand how to build
these servers. So use this as a resource
for yourself and the AI. And the other
thing is I see a lot of MCP servers that
are just not built the best. Like
Chromobb is a good example where it's a
solid MCP server overall, but the way
that they in instantiate their client is
just not ideal. And I don't need to get
into the weeds of this right now, but
it's just not built the best. And then
Mem also did actually release their own
MCP server. So, I'm not building
something completely new, but if you
dive into the code for their MCP server,
again, I don't want to get into the
weeds of this right now. You can clearly
see that they didn't quite understand
how MCP really works. It only supports
one transport and they duplicate the
description for their tools. There's a
lot of things going on here that's not
right. And I don't agree with some of
their decisions. Like, you have to use
the Mem Zero API key. You can't use this
MCP server for free. Like you can use my
Mem Zero MCP server for free. So
honestly, I just feel like mine's a
better version overall. And yeah, it
just seems like no one quite knows at
this point how to truly build an MCP
server correctly. That's what I want to
give you as my gift right now is this as
a template that shows you how to really
build these servers. Well, another thing
really quick. If this template looks
good to you and you want more resources
and templates that look like this and
really give you a good launching pad for
anything you want to build with AI,
check out dynamis.ai. It's an exclusive
community that I recently opened up the
weight list for and I'm going to launch
later this month. I've got a ton of live
events, courses, resources, and
templates like this MCP server all for
you. You can think of it like my YouTube
channel, but going even deeper because
there's only so much I can do on YouTube
each week. I'm going to keep putting out
a ton of valuable content for you here,
but also Dynamus is where you can go
deeper. So, check that out if you're
interested.
Dynamus.ai. But yeah, let's get back to
this template here for building an MCP
server, following all of these best
practices to give you a good head start.
Now, I'm not just trying to get on my
high horse here and tell you that
everything I'm giving you is absolutely
perfect. But what I am telling you is
that I have spent hours and hours of
time researching other MCP servers,
diving into the documentation, building
things myself, and learning through
trial and error. All of this to give you
this template to save you a huge
headache. And so, just please take this
and run with it. And so, what I'll show
you right now is how we can use this
template and other documentation to
build an MCP server. And then also I
want to walk you through the general
structure so you can truly understand
what's going on with these MCP servers
because in the end I'm not a huge fan of
vibe coding. I want you to really
understand what's going on as well. And
so with that let's start with the Python
SDK documentation so you can see at a
high level what goes into a server. And
so it's very easy to get started. You
just pip install MCP and then you can
import fast MCP which is Anthropic's
very easy for way for you to spin up a
server. And so you just with this single
line start your server for MCP. And then
to attach tools in, you just have to do
a little bit of code like this. And so
it's
atmcp.tool. And then the function that
you define below it is now added as a
tool to your MCP server. So now when you
attach your server to something like
cloud desktop, it now has the ability to
call this calculate BMI function and the
LLM will decide the weight and height
and then it'll get the response back. So
it's just like a typical tool call for
an agent that you'd implement with
something else like N8N or Crew AI or
Langchain or Pantic AI whatever it is.
So that's how we add tools to our
servers. It's very very easy. And there
are other components that you can attach
to your servers as well like you can
have prompts that the LLM can fetch as a
template. You can do images. There are
also resources. So this is kind of like
data that you want to keep an LLM
updated with in real time. You can
attach all these different things.
Mostly what people care about these days
though is attaching tools to our server
because that's really what makes the LLM
more agentic when it can do these things
on our behalf using the tools that we
have in MCP server. So that's what I'm
going to focus on in this video. But
really just looking at this
documentation, it makes it seem pretty
simple. We just define our server and
then we attach a bunch of tools and it
mostly is that simple. It's really not
that bad. And on top of this, like I've
been telling you, you can use an AI
coding assistant to make it even easier.
And so, going back to the official MCP
documentation, they literally have a tab
for building MCP with LLMs. So, you go
here and then you can visit this page
for the
LLM-L.ext. And this gives you the full
documentation for MCP in markdown
format. So, you can copy everything here
and then paste that as a part of your
prompt to your LLM. So it now
understands everything with MCP. It's
super nice. And so you can do that. I
can go into Windsurf for example. You
can do this with any AI coding assistant
that you want. And I can just go ahead
and paste in all the documentation.
Boom. There we go. It now understands
MCP completely. And the other thing you
can do with some AI coding assistants
like Windsurf is they support the MCP
documentation natively. So in Windsurf I
can just type at MCP and then hit tab.
And now it's going to use rag to search
to the MCP docs for me. And so there are
other ways you can attach the
documentation as well. But yeah, this is
a very great starting point. And then
you can also paste in my example for my
template. And so essentially what your
prompt is going to look like is you
would say use the MCP docs attached
here. Okay. So then we have the
documentation. Then I'd say also use
this Python MCP server as an example for
the MCP server that you are about to
build. So you give this full example
right here and then at the bottom of the
prompt you would say uh now I want to
build my own MCP server to integrate
with let's just say light rag for
example. I did a video on this recently.
It's a really powerful open source tool
for knowledger graphbased rag. And so we
could build a server just using the AI
coding assistant to essentially have
light rag as a tool now for claw desktop
or N8N whatever we would want. And
that's it. That's all that has to go
into this prompt. And I don't want this
video to be focused entirely on using AI
to build an MCP server. So I'm not going
to send this in and work with this right
now. But that's the general structure
for a prompt for using AI to code the
MCP server. And so what it would spit
out is probably not going to be perfect
right away, but it's going to give you a
good starting point. And hopefully
because it has this template, it'll be
pretty close to perfect. That's one of
the main goals I have with this. We now
know how to use AI coding assistance to
work with MCP and how MCP servers are
structured in general. Now, let's dive
into this template. I'm going to quickly
go through building it from scratch.
I'll just reveal the different
components to you and explain how it all
works together, how I'm implementing the
best practices for MCP2. So the first
thing we have to do after our usual
imports at the top of our Python script
is we want to define the lifespan for
our MCP server. I see a lot of MCP
servers missing this. It is a very core
concept. The reason that we need this is
most MCP servers have some sort of
client like a database connection. It
could be a mem zero client like we have
in this case for setting and retrieving
memories. It could be your superbase
instance. We only want to define one of
those for the entire lifetime of the MCP
server. So for the whole life cycle, we
want to define the client once and then
never have to redefine it again. And
then we also want to be able to do a bit
of cleanup at the end because usually
when you have something like a database
connection, you want to call some sort
of close method to gracefully shut down
the connection to the database. And you
can do that as well in the lifespan. And
so if you've ever implemented an API
endpoint before with something like
express or fast API, you've probably
seen something like a lifespan or life
cycle before. It's kind of like the
singleton pattern as well. If if you're
into software engineering, I mean, don't
worry if you're not. I'm just trying to
make connections for some of you here.
But yeah, it's just very important to
define in our case our mem zero client
and then return that. And this single
client, the same instance is now going
to be available for all of our tool
calls going forward that we'll define in
a bit. So very very important. So it's
added as a part of this context which is
then going to be an argument that's
given to all MCP tools going forward.
We'll see that when we define them. And
so after the lifespan, now we can
instantiate our fast MCP server. So this
will look very similar to what we saw in
the Python SDK documentation. We just
have a couple of extra parameters here
because we're giving it a name and
description. We're defining the lifespan
here. Obviously, we have to include that
in our server. And then for the SSE
transport, I'll explain this more later.
We we want to define our host and port.
So the client will connect to this
specific host and port to reach our MCP
server. And now we get to define all of
our tools. So we're already to the last
component of our MCP server. So just
like we saw in the docs, it's mcp.tool
or whatever the name of your server is.
And then we just define a function that
represents one of the capabilities that
we're giving to our server. And so in
this case, this first function is going
to use mem to save a memory so that our
agent can retrieve it in a future
conversation. And so the context is
given implicitly as the first parameter.
So now we can access the memsure client
that we defined right here. And then the
second parameter everything after the
first one is chosen by the LLM. So it
decides whatever text it wants to save
as a memory. And then also we have this
dock string. And this is actually
crucial because whatever we write right
here is the description for the tool
that's given to the LLM. And so this
will tell it when and how to use this
specific tool in our server. And I'll
even show you this here. If I go to the
MCP server for git that I have hooked in
windsurf right now, all of the slightly
grayed out text that you see for all
these tools that's below each of the
titles, that is this dock string. So
whatever you type here is given as the
description to the LLM. So I hope that
connection makes sense. It's very
important to be descriptive with these.
And then as far as the actual
functionality for the MCP server with
mem zero, I don't want to dive into
memero right now because it's not the
focus of this video, but you can see
that I fetch the client from the
lifespan context like this. And then I
just use it to add a new memory to our
superbase database. It's very nice and
easy. And then I just return a response
to the LLM saying that I successfully
saved the memory. Or if there's any kind
of error, I also alert the LLM of this.
And so this will actually bubble up to
us as the user because this response is
given to the MCP client like claw
desktop and then claw desktop would use
this information either the success or
the error to tell us what happened when
it used this tool. So I hope that all
makes sense. And then for the other two
tools that we have in the server, I
don't want to explain it in too much
detail, but they're also nice and
simple. And so we have one tool to get
all of the memories that we have for our
current user. So again just pulling the
client like we did before from the
context this time using the get all
function to get all the memories that we
have and then in case we have a lot of
memories like hundreds and hundreds we
might want to search for specific ones.
So we also have a tool to do that in a
very similar way. So like I said keeping
it simple there's probably a lot of
other tools you could add from me zero
but I just wanted to show you something
practical but also simple enough where
you can really take this as a template
without having to gut too much
functionality. So if you want you could
just take all these tools and delete
them and then just add your own with
like you know an atmcp.tool and then
define whatever function you want. If
you want to hook into brave or superbase
or light rag whatever you want to do you
can do it. So that's all the tools and
then the very last part of our script is
just a main function. This is where we
really start the server. So we
initialize everything and defined all
the tools at this point but now we can
actually run it. Let me zoom in on this
a little bit right now because this is
very important. Most MCP servers don't
understand this very well from what I've
seen. They usually only make the server
work with one of these different
transport types, but both are important
for different purposes. And I will say
that this whole idea of a transport with
either SSE or standard IO is the most
technical and difficult part to
understand out of everything with MCP
because it's the underlying way that our
clients and servers can communicate with
each other. And so if you really want to
dive into the technicalities of this, I
would suggest reading the core
architecture page of the official MCP
docs. So I don't want to dive into that
in a ton of detail right now just to
spare you that. I want to focus on
building a server, not understanding all
of the tiny tiny details. But we have
two different methods for communicating
with our server. I'm going to zoom in to
really make this easy for you to read
here. We have standard IO, we have SSE.
And as you saw in the script, I handle
both of them. And there's pros and cons
to each. So with standard IO, what it's
going to do is your client is actually
going to start an instance of the server
kind of as a subprocess. So the client
manages the server. It's not what you
would typically have with something like
HTTP. And the reason that you'd want to
use this is it's ideal for local
processes when you have your MCP server
and client running on the exact same
machine. It's very fast. But then we
also have SSE. Now, this is more what
you might be familiar with with HTTP
where you have your browser, your client
that's connected to a server, some API
endpoint. You have that connection that
could also be over the internet. And so,
this is very important if you want to
not just have your MCP server running on
the exact same machine as your client.
This is honestly what I think is more
important overall, especially because I
think the direction we're heading with
MCP servers is everyone wants to run
them remotely to monetize them or just
host them separately from their client.
And then also for certain clients like
N8N, for example, they actually only
support SSE. And so you would have to
build your server for SSE like I'm doing
right here if we want to be able to use
it in something like N8N. And so you can
kind of see with these pros and cons how
we want to support both and that's what
I'm doing in this case. And so there's
an environment variable that you can you
can set. So if you want to look at all
these environment variables just take a
look at the readme that I have at the
root of the repo. But one of them is the
transport that we're using and we can
set this to either SSE or standard IO
depending on the way that we want to
host our server. So, I made it as
adaptable as I possibly could for you,
which is one of those best practices
that I've been telling you about that
I've really tried to make sure I hone in
on for everything that's important for a
server. And so, it's very easy to run
with either. There's just a single
command that we call on our MCP instance
to run with either SSE or standard IO.
So, it takes care of all the hosting
under the hood like with Starlet for
SSSE for example, if you're more
technical and know what that means. Um,
so yeah, trust me, I've gotten really
technical in my research to understand
all of this, so I'm sparing you those
details. At this point, we have
completed our MCP server. And so now,
going back to the readme here, we can
look at the instructions for setting up
everything. And so I have installation
instructions both for Python and if you
want to run things with Docker, which
I'd actually recommend. I think Docker
is just a wonderful tool. It makes
everything more standardized and easy to
work with. And then you can set up all
your environment variables just based on
this guide right here. And a lot of this
will change if you're not using Mem
Zero. So if you are building your own
server, a lot of this might change, but
just for this example, this is
everything you'd have to set up. And
then I have instructions for running it
with Python and Docker as well. And then
what it looks like to connect to it with
your configuration in your MCP client.
So I have you covered for literally
everything. Take a look at this. for
standard IO for Python, standard IO for
Docker. I've got SSE for Python and
Docker. All four ways you could possibly
want to connect to this server. I've got
the configuration for all of that. So,
what I'll do right now, let me actually
open up my terminal. I'll show you here.
So, I'll copy the command to build the
container. So, I'll just copy this and
then I'll just paste it in right here.
And then the port, I'm actually going to
change this to 8070 just because I have
it running already in the other port.
And so, I'll build the container
completely from scratch. I'm just in the
directory that we've been working in
building out our MCP server in that
Python script. And so it's building the
container. It's actually pretty fast
overall. Like MCP servers are pretty
lightweight, which is part of the beauty
of it. So I'll let it do its thing and
run everything. It's already exporting
the final container. And then I can just
go down to the bottom here and let's
just say I want to run it with SSE and
Docker right here. So I'll just copy
this command and then I can clear the
terminal and run this one. And then
boom, there we go. We now have our MCP
server up and running, ready to connect
with any client that we want. So, it's
running on port 8070. So, uh, for
example, I can go into N8N just to
change the port from 8060 like I was
using before to 8070 now. And then I can
ask it the same question. What memories
do I have? So, I want it to tell me for
the 60th time in this video that I like
chicken. Let's see if we get the same
thing. Yep, likes chicken. All right.
And I can even go into the Docker
container and the logs and see that all
the requests from my N8N agent are
coming through right here. Take a look
at that. And we can take this a little
bit further here. Let me actually tell
it I also like
beef. Now chicken and beef are both
great. All right. So I want to store an
updated memory here or maybe a second
memory that I also like beef just so we
can see another tool being used so I'm
not just always asking the exact same
thing. So all right, it updated the
memories. Great. Now, and I can refresh
this and I can now ask it what foods do
I like. So now it should say that I like
chicken and beef. Retrieving both of
those memories. So let's see if we get
the right answer. There we go. You like
chicken and beef. So this server is
working great. And it's all using the
power of MCP for this connection. And
it's so easy to take this and build your
server for literally whatever you want.
And of course, let me know if you have
any questions on this template as you
use it for yourself. If you think
there's anything that I could do to
improve this template, let me know about
that as well, because I really do want
to make this the perfect starting point
for anybody looking to build their own
servers. So, I hope that this video has
really helped you see how easy it is to
build your own MCP server to connect
your AI agents to literally anything.
Also, I have a lot more content coming
out on MCP soon for things like building
out specific use cases and more ways to
leverage this very powerful protocol and
more things for AI agents as well. So,
stay tuned for that. If you appreciated
this video and you're looking forward to
more guides like this, I would really
appreciate a like and a subscribe. And
with that, I will see you in the next